fox news alert potential major
breakthrough in the manhunt for brian
laundry
the fbi confirming that they have what
appears to be human remains at florida
wilderness park along with personal
items belonging to laundry laura ingalls
is in gabby petito's hometown of blue
point new york with the latest laura
hey greg well no confirmation i think a
lot of people were really hoping to hear
the fbi say something about who these
human remains belong to but we did not
get that in that press conference that
happened just moments ago but the fbi
certainly giving us a significant update
in the search for brian laundry and one
other thing that we want to point out
that caught our ear in that press
conference was that they said that brian
laundry was a person of interest in the
murder of gabby petito they've never
used that language before still the fbi
holding this news conference about the
human remains that were found today
listen
earlier today
investigators found what appears to be
human remains
along with personal items
such as a backpack
and notebook belonging to brian laundry
these items were found in an area that
up until recently have been under water
so fox news digital catching chris and
roberta laundry at the park earlier
today where the search activity had
heated up a search team member could be
overheard telling laundry's parents they
might have found something now this is
the same area where brian laundry's
parents told police he had gone for a
hike september 13 then reported him
missing after he did not return to their
northport florida home for several days
cadaver dogs a coroner's van and
investigators seen all around this one
section of the carlton reserve today the
fbi announcing that the area will once
again be closed to the public after it
was just reopened to the public
yesterday i reached out to the family of
gabby petito and their attorney who tell
me that the petito schmidt family will
not be making a comment today and they
do not have plans to do so in the near
future
we've been standing here today in blue
point as you mentioned gabby petito's
hometown we've seen people come and pay
their respects a lot of people are still
waiting for answers as we all do from
the fbi
thanks laura we're going to take it
around the table i have the first
question um the laundry parents decided
to help with the investigation last
night surprise surprise they find the
body the next day i'm assuming it's him
uh did they know where he was the whole
time and number two did is it possible
they made a deal to help find the body
so they wouldn't be charged
a lot of people wondering exactly what
the activity was with chris and roberto
laundry
that is a key question and of course
that time frame they just said you know
we're done searching this area we're
going to wrap it up we're going to open
it up take down that yellow tape and let
the public come in
and then we have this development today
but of course the fbi has been extremely
tight-lipped as all the investigators
are on this case and as you've been
seeing chris and brian laundry as well
not really giving a lot to members of
the media laura it's dana you know about
two weeks ago
mr laundry joined the search
for if you remember that and so
did they i mean you probably don't know
the answer to this but i would be
curious if they went to this spot right
well
these investigators asked chris laundry
to take them to trailheads in areas that
they would know that brian had been to
before you know show us around what what
did he like to do and we we weren't sure
what that all meant and when we saw
chris laundry go in on that golf cart
being you know zinging around with
investigators we weren't sure what to
make of it did he point them in this
direction we've been hearing a lot about
the water levels that have gone down in
just the 24 hours
that led the investigators to this
discovery today again a backpack and a
notebook believed to be brian laundry's
found near these human remains again
they're not making an identification at
this point dana
uh laura katie padlets here wanted to
ask you about kind of this timeline and
the excruciating waiting that the family
and her friends in her hometown have
been going through uh gabby petitto was
reported missing by her family on
september 11th it's now october 20th so
can you talk about what you're seeing
and
what people are looking for in terms of
trying to at least get some closure here
yeah you know we were here just two
weeks ago interviewing the four parents
of gabby petito her mother nicole and
stepfather jim who live here in blue
point her father joe who lives in
florida along with his wife tara we
interviewed all four of them and the one
consistent thing they said was that they
were really hoping that brian laundry is
still hoping that brian laundry would be
found alive they have questions they
want to know what happened on that
cross-country road trip in wyoming they
want answers and not only that of course
if he is found to be responsible they
want justice for gabby
jesse i know you don't have a question
but you have a thought
my thought is the parents are guilty as
sin and they're involved in a conspiracy
to cover up their culpability in this
case
the guy comes home
without his fiancee
and the parents take him camping
and on the camping trip on the way back
they go by cell phones they all go by
cell phones now the cops looked at the
cell phones they didn't have any
evidence on them but did they also buy
burner phones did they buy a solar
charger because it appears like the
parents were in communication with this
guy brian possibly with the burner
phones through the attorney the
attorney's dirty attorney is crooked
obviously and if the brian guy calls the
attorney the attorney then tells the
parents what's going on with brian it's
privileged confidential information you
can't tap it can't even ask any
questions about it so maybe they don't
hear from brian for a while maybe he's
out there and it just so happens you
nailed it greg the one time both parents
go out looking they happen to stumble
upon personal items we're hearing that
probably was a gator that got dirty
laundry in that little swamp we don't
know yet we're going to wait to see but
they could hit him with a slew of
charges the parents here you have
accessory after the fact this murder
committed on federal land you heard them
use the word murder now that is whoever
knowing that a defense against the
united states has been committed
receives relieves comforts or assists
the offender in order to hinder or
prevent his apprehension trial or
punishment your accessory after the fact
that in a murder case that's 15 years
right there you could do harboring you
could do obstruction if they destroyed
any evidence aiding and abetting
accessory to unlawful flight i would
lean so hard on these parents it's
obviously they know something and
they've been hiding it and the family of
gabby deserves justice and if that's
what justice means so be it
harold what are your thoughts i i'd like
just one question for laura if she's
still there harold ford laura did they
have there are there any other persons
of interest the only person that we've
heard just publicly consuming this awful
awful story is that uh brian laundry was
the person of interest are there any
other leads or or people that the fbi or
any law enforcement might might be
targeting or might have targeted
yeah no they have only said that brian
laundry was a person of interest and and
i do want to know that in today's press
conference and all throughout this
investigation they have repeatedly
agents have repeatedly said they still
want people to come forward you may hear
this news today and say well there was
remains that were found in florida
they're still looking for people to come
forward you know we we've heard about
all these witnesses that saw the couple
fight brian and gabby along the way of
their summer trip they're still looking
for more information if anybody saw
anything to come forward and help them
kind of piece this all together but to
answer your question no no other persons
of interest have been identified
thanks laura great job